[Music]
but you know don't forget you saw what
tim poole said
uh buy my food buckets
no no no first off he said did you see
that sick ollie i did
and then oh no no no i remember what tim
tim paul said um
give me my money or i'm not giving you
your cat back allegedly
okay that is something that he may have
said but he also
oh that oh no you're talking about the
time he said to his own flesh and blood
if you say another word about me on
twitter my lawyers will [ __ ] destroy
you
yes he did say that but tim poole also
said hey give me my hat back
okay seriously millennial man looked at
him and said no
tim poole actually said uh on twitter
something to the effect of like i don't
interact with or not
with anonymous people on on twitter
people shouldn't be anonymous
on the internet they should say what
they are and then he went into like i
gave up my job at disney
in my life and i've been threatened but
at least i use my real name
so he thinks that you're not a lot he
also invoked the founding fathers
that the founding fathers used their
real names so people shouldn't be
anonymous
um on twitter they should all have some
skin in the game and all lose their jobs
and not be able to provide for their
families
yeah they have that um that's the uh jim
norton said that before
a lot of other like comedians always do
like anybody that gets mildly famous
and starts to get trolled a lot
immediately is like everyone should be
registered on the internet all right
candace owens calm down
yeah temple doesn't [ __ ] under well
he doesn't understand he heals what he's
talking about
but simple doesn't get that you know
the reason people are more anonymous on
the internet is because they want to be
able to
say what they believe without having to
lose their [ __ ] livelihood
you know without having to lose their
life you know i i
look mike and i put her name out there
whatever i don't care but
some people do and i get that you know
people have a lot to lose
and tim poole thinks that because you
know he's doing it that he
he basically compared himself to the
founding [ __ ] fathers bro
well he is a lot like the founding
fathers like
and and and the fact that he that he
says does he know how many people
during 1776 does he know how many of the
people
were were being anonymous and helping
out like the [ __ ] government
overthrow england it was a lot of people
i mean just because you see alexander
hamilton who for some reason is puerto
rican now
and you know his name it doesn't [ __ ]
mean that there weren't a lot of people
that were doing that and and temple's
such a [ __ ] baby
he doesn't like it because anonymous
people bother him i don't know what the
difference is
you know yeah also getting his name out
there like
that he is is why he's rich now so he
needs to shut up it's not like he
all he's ever done since he horde
himself out
ideologically is make a fortune so
what is he complaining about like tim
poole hasn't suffered
at all like the people that complain the
people that complain the most
on twitter and [ __ ] and on their youtube
shows about how much they've suffered
are always the ones that have suffered
the least
none of us are suffering by the way like
there's setbacks to this if you want to
put your name and face out there
you're gonna face some [ __ ]
repercussions that is life
but it's like i mean make it where it's
it's worth it like this show's worth it
what we've done is worth it
but so we're not we're never gonna be
like oh my god we're martyrs like
this has been worth it like we built up
a thing yeah we're not making tim pool
bucks
but you know this thing's turned out to
be pretty successful
so you know it's it's i hate when people
like get successful by doing a thing and
then complain about the thing like oh
god i'm just a martyr no you're not
you're famous and rich
shut up holy [ __ ] he did a 13-part tweet
bro
of course he did because he's a woman
temple is a female he's biologically
timpul is a biologically a female
here's what he said stop responding to
people who don't use their name or
actual avatar and watch discourse track
to drastically improve
i never said people are not allowed to
talk i said i have better conversations
when people show themselves
why should i be the only one to put my
face and name on the line for what i
believe
do you know how much money tim poole
makes
it's a [ __ ] ridiculous ludicrous
amount
i quit and sued two companies before i
had a twitter account
i quit two massive media companies
offering me the world
you can't even stand by your own names
and that is likely why you've nev
you will never have one
my entire pitch has been that people
need to stand up and speak out and push
back are you surprised by me not
agreeing with you
but the problem is [ __ ] tim when you
sue two companies
you didn't have a family to provide for
you were living in a [ __ ] van
like he wants people that have a job at
a factory
who are going to get [ __ ] completely
nuked off the planet
if they say anything is not the same as
having what are they going gonna take
from you tim
your collection of guitars and your
skateboards
really sick of this [ __ ] i'm really
sick of this [ __ ]
yeah i'm uh responding right now
actually oh my producer is
i'm type i'm writing to my producer
telling him what to tweet
jesus christ
francis lewis had his home raided
presumably because he signed
his wife was taken prisoner and used a
prisoner exchange okay
so we should have our home rated right
we should all be put on no fly list and
never be able to see our grandparents
again
because tim poole doesn't want to argue
with anons
one signer died from the wounds in the
battle uh
button gwenett his name his honor and
his life the founding fathers risked
everything not just their lives their
fortunes and their land
but their lives on their families they
signed knowing that they had just
declared a war
the greatest military power in the world
says tim poole
who edited an alex jones interview
[ __ ] [ __ ] war hero tim poole who
re
i haven't forgotten timmy boy that when
he had alex jones on
he says you can't say that he took the
episode down and edited the alex jones
interview
because he was afraid youtube was gonna
come after him tim paul follows youtube
toss to the t
you're not putting your [ __ ] out there
we haven't [ __ ] been monetized in two
years you [ __ ] loser
get the [ __ ] out of here we weren't
allowed for the first six months of
doing this show to be on youtube because
of the [ __ ] we were saying
and he wants you to get dox and lose
your family but he's gonna edit an alex
jones interview i
[ __ ] cannot stand this grifting food
bucket piece of [ __ ] i'm so sick of him
i'm so [ __ ] sick of him
he's comparing himself to founding
fathers
several of the signers saw their homes
looted during the war forging
as british not direct retaliation walter
rutledge middleton
ellie hall gwenet climber hayward you
are a piece of [ __ ] the one thing that
is true is that these men risked
everything and even their wives and
children
maybe we view this recklessness today
when it comes to personal endeavors
but these men saw it as necessary okay
tim then here's what's necessary
[ __ ] say something out of youtube
terms of service go ahead tim
but we we do it all the time by the way
go ahead tim
[ __ ] do it show me what a [ __ ] man
you are but you're not because you want
those [ __ ] paychecks
and you're not because you're pretending
the world's going to end so you could
sell
[ __ ] food buckets suck a dick tim
[ __ ] seriously you could suck a
[ __ ] dick
i am really sick of this guy pretending
like he's a [ __ ] founding father
when he could even maintain a
relationship with his co-host and his
co-host is doing his
show but he's but his co-host is still
living in the same house but doing his
own
show which is weird i was just
pluralizing it for you because i wasn't
the first co-host he burned through yeah
his own brother can't stand him yeah i
mean the the [ __ ] fact that tim poole
is equating edit he's [ __ ] edited
stuff
the [ __ ] that he's [ __ ] done
and then he says you can't be anonymous
on the internet [ __ ] you tim how about
that
and by the way you know my name tim i
don't give a [ __ ] about you tim to be
honest with you
but i'm not worried about you timmy boy
but i'm just pointing that out like
remember we covered the alex jones and
we covered him when alex jones
we got to kill people and he's like you
can't oh my god you can't say that
i gotta make the episode private i gotta
hide the episode oh no
oh no they're going to find out that
alex shut up tim
and by the way i'm issuing an ultimatum
as of right now
um my producer's twitter account um
94 people that adam goldman follows
follow tim poole adam goldman
in the next 48 hours will begin
unfollowing
every single person who follows tim
poole
[ __ ] let's do that if you're watching
this right now
unfollow tim poole please
by the way all these people suck at tim
pool's dick wasn't he a bernie bro
yeah they all were him and cassandra tim
pulls a [ __ ]
business partners now temple's a [ __ ]
bernie bro
and then he saw the money come in and
all of a sudden he [ __ ] turned into
[ __ ] oh i'm a conservative i fight
for free speech you were gonna vote us
into socialism
people that [ __ ] follow this fool are
real
honestly don't forget that cassandra
fairbanks business partner also during
the george floored riots
uh uploaded a video to twitter of like
fireworks going off
way in the distance and her neighborhood
was like totally quiet
and then she's like oh the rest of the
video cut out like but black lives
matter and antifa doxed me and
surrounded my house
my child lives here i'm scared and then
she did a gofundme and literally bought
a new house
and nobody was nobody ever came for her
they're all scumbags
but yes unfollow tim poole do something
good today
if you're seeing this and you're
listening to me unfollow
tim poole and unfollow cassandra
fairbanks and may i add another one
unfollow ian miles chong unfollow those
three people
because they're all everything that
comes out of their mouth is a grift
yeah jim edwards quoting one of our
rejoiners the family guy thing it's not
art it's commerce but
nothing better describes tim pool than
that it's not
art it's [ __ ] commerce look hey
i will admit we we we do live reads we
we have we have companies that support
us
absolutely but let's be honest we kind
of do them
whatever way we want and uh we
don't really change our opinion on the
world ending because of what [ __ ] my
book he says
you know what i mean i've never been
like guys the world's gonna end you
better bet on the lightning
you know but he changes the world's
gonna get your food buckets you need to
survive
you need to survive why don't you
[ __ ] survive by eating skateboards
you disingenuous piece of [ __ ]
i am [ __ ] sick of this guy
sorry i don't know why i got really mad
i'm sorry it's friday it's fun
guys just just unfollow tim pool
supposed to be fun